-Here's how it works.
On your turn, you're gonna
stick your head
into the TV set over there,
and we're going to magically
move your eyes and mouth
onto a photo
of a famous musician.
Then you have to give
your partner clues
to get them
to guess that artist.
You have 90 seconds to guess
as many right as you can,
and each picture
is worth 1,000 points.
Joel, will.i.am, you go first.
Keke, Saweetie, you can
watch from over there.
-Okay.
-I'll see you soon.
Alright, you two.
-Okay.
-Alright.
-Who's going to give the clues?
Who's going to guess?
-Uh...
-Who's going to put their head
through the TV set?
-I will [bleep] this up, so...
-No, no, hey.
It's a family show.
-Oh, it's a family show?
-Yeah, it is.
-My kids say [bleep]
all the time.
-No, it wasn't that.
It was the word "up."
-Oh, I see.
-It was the word "up"
that we can't say.
-I don't know.
-We can say the "F" word. Yep.
-Again, as being the most
talented musician here...
-Yes.
-Why don't I go...
-Alright, Joel,
you get in there. Yeah.
-Is that alright?
-Yeah.
-You're gonna sit right here.
will.i.am, sit
in the grandpa chair.
Relax. Enjoy yourself.
Here's the remote.
-Hey, look, it's your beard!
-Jimmy.
-Oh, my God. It is my beard.
Yeah. No, Joel --
-I can't see anything!
-No. Joel, put your --
Other way.
Turn around.
[ Laughter ]
That's much better.
That's much better. Yeah.
Alright, let's get...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You look good right there.
It looks really good.
Let's get 90 seconds
on the clock.
-I've been working out.
-Here comes the first picture.
♪♪
-Okay, this is -- this is three
women, and they sing together,
but two of them
no longer sing with them.
-Oh. Uh...Destiny's Child.
-Yes.
-Wow.
-Alright, this is the guy
that plays a saxophone
and has one letter
for his last name.
-Kenny G.
-Yes.
-This guy always has
a Band-Aid on his face.
-Oh, oh, Nelly.
-Yes.
-Oh, king of rock 'n' roll
from Memphis, Tennessee.
-Oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh! Elvis Presley!
-Oh, nice. Nice. You got it.
From the band Kiss.
He always sticks his tongue out.
-Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
-He's always.
-Pass, pass, pass, pass.
-Okay.
Oh, she always shakes her butt,
and she's from South America.
-Oh, Anitta.
-Wow. Who's that?
-Anitta, too, though.
-She's got -- Pass.
I'm passing.
Am I allowed to pass?
-Yes, you're allowed to pass.
-He's the biggest star
out of Canada.
He's got all the hits ever.
-Celine Dion!
-No, he's a dude. One dude.
-Justin Bieber!
-No. He was on "Degrassi."
-Drake! -Drake!
-He was on --
Oh. Huge country star.
She's blond.
She was on "American Idol."
Gigantic,
biggest name in country.
-Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Shania Twain.
-"Jesus, Take the Wheel."
"Jesus, Take the Wheel."
You know it.
You love country music.
I can tell, will.i.am.
-Um, um, um, um, um, um...
-Pass.
It's Carrie Underwood.
[ Laughter ]
-Joel, come here.
-Okay, we gonna get this, boo.
-We are.
-You did great.
You did great.
-Did we do great?
-Yes, you did really great.
You can both
have a seat over there
and swap with Keke and Saweetie.
Come on over, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did we do -- I don't know.
Did we do well?
-I hope Drake doesn't
get pissed.
-Now, Who -- Who --
Who wants to guess
and who wants to give the clues?
Do you want to guess?
-I think we should do
what we did last time
'cause you did
a lot of good guessing.
-So, you want to do the clues.
-I'll do the clues.
-Okay. So I'll do the guessing.
-Alright.
Keke, here's your remote in case
you want to change the channel.
-Alright.
-Go enjoy our chair.
Saweetie, go around here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's perfect. Super cute.
-Look at her cute little face
coming through.
-Yeah, the cute little --
Aww, come on. That's so cute.
Yes. Perfect.
-She's just so cute.
-Alright. Ready?
I think you're gonna crush it.
-I'm very excited, Jimmy.
-You're gonna crush this.
-You know I don't like to lose.
-Well, you know,
it's fun 'cause we do Password
and you're the host
and then you never got a chance
to play until one game.
-And now I -- know.
-But now you're playing.
-Yes!
-And you're the best person
to play with.
Alright, let's see how many
points you can rack up here.
Alright. Can we get
90 seconds on the clock?
Get ready to face the music.
♪♪
-Oh. Beyoncé is married to him.
-Jay-Z.
-Mm-hmm.
♪ Tick-tock on the clock ♪
-Kesha.
-Yep.
He's right behind you.
-Oh, will.i.am.
-Yep.
-Um...
Um, that's my best friend.
She a real --
-Saweetie!
-The other girl.
-Doja Cat?
-Yes. Um...
Zoe Kravitz is his daughter.
-Oh, Lenny Kravitz.
-Mm-hmm.
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
-Usher.
[ Ding! ]
-[ Laughs ]
-They're not the
Backstreet Boys. They're --
-NSYNC.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
- ♪ Let's get it
start up on... ♪
-Mary J. Blige!
-That's right, girl!
-Um...okay.
-White rapper, cool 50 Cent,
mom's spaghetti.
-Oh, Eminem.
-Yep.
-Um, Rihanna is his ba--
is his -- her -- is his --
is her baby daddy.
A$AP Rocky.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Um...um...
Loo-- Um...
Ooh, it's my girl.
"Luxurious."
-Oh, Fergie.
Oh. No, no. Gwen Stefani.
-Yeah, girl. Um...
If you if you ain't acting
grown, you acting what?
-Childish Gambino.
[ Ding! ]
-Ohh!
-Yep. Oh, God. Ooh.
Who's this?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
That is how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on over here, buddy.
Whoa! That is how you do it
right there.
-Childish Gambino.
[ Laughter ]